is here
he has he has a book called Interstellar
and I will be putting links shortly so
Sam what's the difference between the
Avi that I'm speaking to right now and
then what you feel like is your true Avi
which is off camera you I don't know if
do you feel like it's your true self is
due with your wife are you with your
family or is it something else maybe
you're out in nature you feel like
that's you
well there is no difference and uh by
the way
um the way I view my body you know I
received it from my parents and just
like buying a car from a dealer you're
not responsible for the parts that make
it and uh so I don't feel any special
connection to what I call myself I mean
I just carry it around with me it's not
as if I understand my internal organs
better than I understand other people's
organs better
um and so um all together
um you know what I'm really curious
about is you know the universe the
reality that we all share and
um to me that that is a fascinating
Journey trying to figure it out and you
know when I will get closer to death and
that would not frighten me I was asked
actually today on a podcast what do I
want the writing to be on on my tune
Tombstone and uh I said that's something
that is not particularly important for
me because well first of all I'm hopeful
that every year that passes and our
lifespan will increase by more than a
year so that I will live forever but if
it doesn't happen you know I would much
rather have an artificial intelligence
system an AI system that sort of follows
on my guiding principles and carries my
flame of Consciousness into the future
and in a way that will be the same Avi
but now machine learning and you would
be able to interact with it and I think
we are getting to that time where AI
systems will replace people after they
die and you know then I would feel much
better about it because the physical
death of my body is just like you know a
car stopping stops working and you just
put it in a junkyard but if you have a
newer car that functions better and does
the same things then nothing is lost
great great answer Dan so Abby also
Jackson ask him about anything
so tonight yes hello guys so this is the
first time deck I'm I'm meeting you
isn't it
[Music]
good evening yeah this is the first time
that's it's right that's right
um I'm not a UFO uh I'm not very
knowledgeable on UFO so I UFO so I don't
know how much I can contribute to this
section
sorry you were in the middle
oh yeah so I I just sounded really
curious when having about transfer and
his his Consciousness into a new car so
to speak
um does that kind of speak to whether
Abby thinks Consciousness is emergent or
fundamental to the universe
yeah I do think that we are just a
complex machine you see and uh the way
to prove it is if we construct out of
silicon computers that would be sentient
you know that we will have a sentient AI
hopefully within a decade or maybe
already in some places
um you know then it will be clear that
it's an emergent phenomena if you can't
tell the difference between uh an AI
system and a human then there is no
difference okay because uh you know we
are complex and obviously we imagine
that there is something extra but
um you know I think death of a person
might be just like unplugging a computer
from the wall and ultimately when we
will have sentient AI systems we will
not be allowed to unplug them from the
wall just like we are not allowed to
pull a trigger and kill a person of
course there could be Electric outages
that are unintended
because there is something I like to say
about this if
he please go Jack please come in please
yeah it may be stupid but it's uh the
way I think about this about artificial
intelligence it's it in the end it may
look like a sentence that's always the
question does it rather look like
sentient so Consciousness or is it
really conscience but the my main
problem with artificial intelligence
being well conscience or not or sentient
is that sure we do we train artificial
intelligence to do certain stuff but in
the end the program is the one who
selects which
Direction the AI should go in you
if you're a program you have certain
weights to certain
um
endpoints you want to reach so yeah
I assume that you don't have children
no right because if you had children you
would realize that their parents have a
very important role to play when they
educate a child as to what the child is
thinking
and I don't see any difference between
educating a child and guiding a very
sophisticated AI algorithm so that at
the end of the day you know millions or
billions of people will not be able to
tell the difference between them
chatting with that AI system and them
chatting with a person now you can
always think that we are we have a
superiority but this is just wishful
thinking if you if nobody can tell the
difference then there is no difference
well it's necessary not necessarily
superiority it's just there's a certain
thing going on that we don't understand
and that is that is how we we make these
value judgments in the first place so we
can teach an AI to uh approach a certain
direction we like but we cannot
necessarily formalize the way we do this
what I'm telling you is that when you
educate a kid
you are also doing the same thing
yes but the kid already has a propensity
to uh use that same system that that
uses values and we don't know exactly
how that works at least that's that's if
I listen to John for fake or things like
that humans are not computers and there
are there's there are some good reasons
you can wishfully say humans are not
computer you can wishfully say oh the
computer is dumb you know it's just a
machine I'm superior you can say a lot
of things but as a matter of fact if I
have the touring test to billions of
people for decades and nobody can tell
the difference between a computer and a
person then to me there is no difference
now you can talk philosophically about
differences but if there is no way to
tell the difference then there is no
difference that's fair enough that's
fair enough because I do agree with you
that that will you know probably in our
lifetime become a point that that we
will not be able to tell the difference
at least through through chat the next
problem is making a cyborg that actually
looks like a human and
muscles that actually work
we were talking about Consciousness and
if you ever I actually had Stephen
Hawking at my home okay Stephen Hawking
could not move a muscle
okay so it's not a matter of being cool
or not cool I'm just telling you he
could not move a muscle
he could not he barely moved his eyebrow
so then you are telling me that the body
of Stephen Hawking was actually much
more than the body of a computer no
because both of them cannot behave like
a cyborg I don't need a cyborg in order
to definitely Stephen Hawking had
Consciousness nobody doubts yeah yeah I
agree I agree he even had affairs with
the people with one of the nurses that
took care of him so obviously he had a
Consciousness it has nothing to do with
having a seaborg reproducing our ability
to run to lift things nothing because he
didn't lift anything he didn't move he
couldn't even move the the chicks on his
face so you would not say that Stephen
Hawking had no consciousness
while on the topic of artificial
intelligence Avi I interviewed back in
2021 and there was one question that I
didn't get to ask and I think now's just
a great moment to ask that and that is
in your opinion what is the percentage
estimate like How likely is it that some
UFOs if not from our world are actually
piloted by AI rather than biological
entities can you give us your thoughts
on this yeah I think it's very likely
because you see um biological creatures
were selected by Natural Evolution to
survive on a rock like the Earth with an
atmosphere and you know quite balanced
conditions if you put them in space
first of all they would not be long
lived enough to survive the journey it
takes even for at the speed of light it
takes tens of thousands of years to
cross the Milky Way galaxy and if you
move at the speed of a chemical rocket
it takes 10 000 times longer so it takes
you know
half a billion years to cross the Milky
Way galaxy there is no way a biological
creature would first of all have the
patience and second have the ability to
survive for that long uh in in the
Hazardous conditions of space so my
point is it makes much more sense to
send an AI astronaut once we develop
those sentient systems that can machine
learn adapt to new circumstances they
can be dormant for millions of years so
if we are thinking about those being the
um you know Messengers for us into
Interstellar space other civilizations
probably reach the same conclusions now
this could also include biological
creatures that have augmentation to
their you know organs and with
technological gadgets and devices but my
point is it has to be it cannot be just
biology it has to be technology that
accommodates the you know the weaknesses
of biological systems and and therefore
if we find anything in our neighborhood
I would you know I would put my bet on
AI systems if they are functional and
then to figure them out may be difficult
may not be trivial we may need our own
AI systems but I completely agree with
you and I think that's most likely for
what we might find the interesting
question is whether we are really the
first civilization that ever existed on
Earth or on Mars was there a
civilization you know a few billion
years ago and when we say two or three
billion years ago we're talking just
about a factor of two uh earlier and we
are we are 4.6 billion years after the
Earth was made or after Mars were made
you know I don't think it's out of the
question that there was a technological
civilization when Mars was 2 billion
years old why not a factor of two on
mars or on Earth
apparently sorry you said two billion
years when Mars was 2 billion years old
do you mean that the civilization may
have been on mars or on Earth at that
point
either place because Mars was
similar to Earth in fact it had
habitable conditions before Earth uh
because it occurred earlier and it's
possible that um you know simple biology
started on Mars it's much more likely
that it started on Mars earlier than on
Earth because we believe there was
liquid water over there and all I'm
saying is if it took 4.6 billion years
for us to come to the stage it's
possible that someone else came to the
stage two and a half billion years ago
and in that case when Mars became not so
habitable because if if that
Civilization realized for example that
it's about to lose its atmosphere and
lose all of its liquid water on the
surface they would ask themselves think
about it it would enter the political
discussion on Mars they would ask
themselves what do we do oh there is
this planet next to us called the Earth
and it has no oxygen in the atmosphere
what should we do terraform Earth maybe
we should put you know a mask on Mars
so when when Mars lost its atmosphere
around the same time somewhere between
two to two point five billion years ago
that was exactly the time when there was
a sudden increase in the oxygen level on
Earth before that there was not much
oxygen in the atmosphere around that
time
cyanobacteria started to produce huge
vast amounts of oxygen now of course
most most scientists think well it may
have been just a natural
process that led to that but we don't
know why the Earth's oxygen level in the
atmosphere suddenly jumped at around the
same time when Mars lost its atmosphere
and I say you know maybe someone
terraformed Earth
[Applause]
appreciate it
was a great problem what's one of your
whole memories
sorry what's one of your earliest
memories and then I keep we keep having
the same intuition just jumping at the
same time I apologize man what were you
gonna say no it's fine
um
I was just gonna say thank you for both
the question and the answer because both
were really fascinating
thank you uh in terms of first memory to
me the most traumatic memory of my
childhood I had a wonderful childhood
you know in in a on a farm but the most
I mean the the scar that was left by my
childhood was that when I was sitting at
the dinner table with a lot of adults in
the room I would ask a difficult
question and they would just dismiss the
question because they didn't know the
answer and they didn't want to embarrass
themselves by showing ignorance and to
me it was obvious that they don't know
the answer sometimes they would invent
an answer that made no sense and I
thought that by becoming a scientist you
know I will be able to address questions
you know using the scientific method and
figure it out myself but what do I find
in Academia exactly the same phenomena
people pretending they know the answer
in advance not
showing not
um admitting that they are ignorant and
you know that's about things that do not
quite line up with what we expect
including the first interest there are
objects
welcome Bernardo castrov of Essentia
Foundation the links will be displayed
on the screen Choice thank you happy
holidays good to see you even sound
effects happy holidays everybody yeah
thank you you're welcome
hey Jack sorry about those sounds if you
keep hearing them that's just this ball
that I'm sitting on I'm it makes noises
so what's New Mexico
and have you met Avi before
pleasure to see you nice to meet you
Bernardo what's new what's what have you
been working on what are you looking
forward to in 20 in 2023
full
um my holidays are over uh in 2023 my
diamond has a decreed that I have to
write two books my publisher decreeded
that too so that's uh that helps so I
have to get my act together and not only
run essential Foundation but produce
something of my own again as well I only
wrote A Few essays this year nothing
nothing really serious but next year
I'll get serious
do two books do another computer one
computer a year keeps the Mind clear so
that will go on but I have to do some
serious writing that's my New Year's
resolution and my prey
my my wish to God is that the war ends
uh so you are religious is that right
I think I am religious in the original
sense of really God I I care very much
about being
connected with something outside time
um I think that's very important I think
it's the greatest loss of Western
culture since the middle of the 19th
century or so
okay you know if we find X in
extraterrestrial
kid that is smarter than us it may be an
approximation to God
I would I would be very afraid of that
that we would you know follow this this
this this this alley that leads nowhere
saying that we sort of replace Divinity
with
a poor alternative a vessel upon which
we project the numinosity of the Divine
if you know all I'm saying is religious
texts talk about
God creating life creating the universe
and suppose I bring you an advanced
scientific civilization that can create
life in the laboratory it's not
completely it's not mediocre it's not
inferior it creates life in the
laboratory and it also creates baby
universes in the laboratory it's exactly
what you are hoping for it exists but
it's scientists in a white lab coat that
are doing this it's not something else
would that disappoint you completely I
think that would be literally insane I
think what you just described is not my
notion of divinity at all I think this
is a
we want God to do other than create a
whole universe what else I don't see
Divinity as a personified ego and a kind
of egoic agency that has power over us
that's not my notion of divinity we
didn't talk about ego we just I just
said what that entity can do so what
else can it do that you imagine that is
better than creating a universe
my notion of divinity has very very
little to do with power with what it can
do
we are talking past each other I don't
think we will resolve this in a
15-minute conversation but let the
record just reflect that my my my notion
of divinity that thing I want to have a
relationship with has very very little
to do with everything we just described
that that's not Divinity to me that's
just power it's a very different thing
okay by that by that you didn't Define
it
Bernardo are you able to go into what it
is that you define or you see as
Divinity or you feel as Divinity in a
couple minutes or is that it's going to
mislead rather than probably it will I
would try because otherwise people would
think no he makes these statements and
then he runs away and refuses to Define
so sure sure
just so you know this whole environment
was supposed to be one of a of a pub and
now I feel like this is the one it is
still a pub after a few drinks and you
get into the weeds
I'm drinking hydrogen oxide here and
and just I mean so people know in case
they're thinking that there's some some
anger here this is just like no it's
just how academics talk because if we
just like to question ideas
Divinity to me is not personified it's
not an agent separate from its creation
Divinity is something that transcends
space and time uh Divinity is what
psychology with us would associate with
the notion of numinosity the numinous
Divinity is something that is
because it's outside time you can't say
that it's old or young but you skirt it
you get closer to it if you say
uh it's what was there before the Big
Bang it's what is always there it's the
Fountain Head of
of existence of the Dynamics of the
universe it's it's the most foundational
layer of nature which as most of you
know in my view it is a field of
subjectivity divinity is that field of
subjectivity unencumbered by a
dissociative process and in that sense
it is
um omniscient literally not in the way
you would want to understand it as
metacognitively uh conscious of
everything I don't think it is that I
don't think it's metacognitive at all
but it's the foundational layer of our
own being and if you introspect deep
enough which is almost impossible for
the vast majority of us certainly for me
but if I could introspect deep enough
and peel the onion of my being
progressively more and more layers more
and more layers that nothing that would
be left at the end that nothing that is
pregnant with everything that is
divinity
okay I just wanted to clarify I will not
dwell much on this but whatever you said
at the beginning is exactly what I was
saying it's something that happened
before the Big Bang it's just a
scientist in a white lab coat that
created the Big Bang was before time as
we Define it in the Big Bang and is the
source of everything and I just talked
about it as a scientist in a lab coat
you talk about it as something that you
peel your onions on your layers off and
I you know to me I I don't know what
that is I don't know what's left of your
onion layers after you peel them off but
I'm saying the source of everything we
have if it created our big bang
this is a very nice fantasy it's a story
to tell children you know science is in
a lab coat dressed in a white lab coat
created our universe now cute it's very
cute but of course the intended meaning
that I had when I referred to the Big
Bang was something that existed before
the beginning of time in other words
before the Big Bang of the universe of
your fantasized scientists your super
powerful transhuman scientist whatever
whatever it is that was intended meaning
but look we will talk past each other
because I know where you're coming from
I don't know you but your past few words
already put up you know like an outdoor
board in front of me announcing where
you're coming from and I know that space
very well I spent most of my life in
that space there is no way I will make
sense to you in 15 minutes
this is something we need to spend the
weekend together and then maybe you will
have an intuition for why I say what I
say despite my extremely Western
rational background with two doctorates
and having worked at CERN and all that
stuff
okay
I just wanted to remind you of the
Chicken and the Egg problem you may ask
what was before the chicken that was an
egg and what was laying the egg a
chicken so uh was there something before
the Chicken and the Egg the answer is
yes something else that's the true
answer for what happened on Earth
because we know that before the Chicken
and the Egg existed there was something
else and the same may be true for the
universe that's all I'm saying
okay
all right the theolocution between Avi
lobe and Bernardo Castro's schedule this
January 8th 2018. five hours long
so Milestone whilst we're talking about
definitions can I ask Abby Jack
Christina could as well Billy we were
talking about Abby you mentioned Stephen
Hawking and and how his life was you
know he he couldn't move uh he used the
computers kind of communicate and when
we think of Being Human we think of a
certain type of person you know two arms
two legs we can talk and that kind of
thing but obviously Stephen Hawking is a
human but just is outside of that
definition so I wanted to ask you all uh
what what do you guys think it mean be
human
um
well I I if you ask me I would say uh
being conscious of the reality that that
we we share uh because many you know at
least some living things we we don't see
a Consciousness in them like you know
plants for example or so well you know
vegetables so in principle uh you know I
would say that being conscious is is
what makes us human it's not so much our
bodily Parts because people lose limbs
you know a soldier that goes to work and
lose a limb uh as long as the soldier is
alive
uh the soldier is human
and then and if you degrade all physical
abilities you end up in a state similar
to Stephen Hawking at the end of his
life but he started from being just like
any of us as a young kid so it's just
that his muscles stopped working and you
know that shows you that if you reduce a
human what remains is simply the
Consciousness that's my take on it and
if we are able to produce AI systems
that are conscious
then we got it you know it's basically
an emergent phenomena that you know
identifies a very complex system
um and there are much more primitive
systems that are alive that are not
capable of this and so when we talk
about humans it's because they are able
to understand the reality that they live
in being conscious that would be my
definition
of course many people would say love you
know the fact that we can relate to each
other yeah of course
all right you just watched a clip from
an eight hour live stream Behemoth
Leviathan podcast from theories of
everything which is a channel where we
explore physics mathematics and
Consciousness what is the Theory of
Everything how do you merge Quantum
field Theory with the general
relativities click here or in the
description for the full podcast where
there are several people make
appearances all the way from George
Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary Nolan to
Avi lope to John verakee to Donald
Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description